Hello everyone! I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward for Going Green.
But today, we're actually going blue.
In honor of the world's oceans.
Without water, the earth would be just another ordinary planet in the solar system.
But our vast, blue ocean sustain life on land as well as underwater.
That's why the World Ocean's conference in Coral Triangle Summit...
...brought together leaders and environmentalists...
...from more than a hundred countries in Manado, Indonesia.
The initial idea on it was to really bring world experts into the Coral Triangle region...
...and focus on major fishery issues and major marine issues around the world.
It then became much more of a climate change focused event.
When we think of climate change, polar bears often come to mind...
...but warming weather is not just a threat to the Arctic ice cap.
Frazer McGilvray is director of the Coral Triangle Initiative at Conservation International.
There are some experts now saying that by the end of the century...
...that we could see a hundred,...
...we could see a sea level rise of one meter,...
...which is massive in certain parts of the world.
Warmer water will affect the marine life quite severely, particularly coral reefs.
If we exceed those thermal limits, the coral reefs will die.